In the last 10 years, global insect
populations collapsed by 41%.
Sit with that for a minute. Imagine if
nearly half of the people on Earth
suddenly died.
So what happened? A new, smarter species
took over, humans. In the blink of an
eye, we poisoned the air, raised
forests, and replaced ecosystems with
concrete, steel, and monocrops.
Scientists call this the sixth mass
extinction. But unlike Earth's previous
five mass extinctions, this one is being
caused by us. We've transformed 50% of
Earth's land into farmland. We didn't
mean to wipe out the bugs. We just
didn't care. And now more and more of
the world's top AI scientists are
warning of a seventh mass extinction.
Not caused by us, but by something we're
creating. The godfather of AI, who just
won the Nobel Prize, explains,
>> "Once these artificial intelligences get
smarter than we are, they will take
control. They'll make us irrelevant."
Alarm bells over the artificial
intelligence are deafening. And they are
loudest from the developers who designed
it. The scientists and experts have
called on the world to act, declaring AI
an existential threat to humanity on a
par with the risk of nuclear war.
Max Tegmark says it has happened many
times before that species were wiped out
by others that were smarter. We humans
have already wiped out a significant
fraction of all the species on Earth.
That is what you should expect to happen
as a less intelligent species, which is
what we are likely to become given the
rate of progress of artificial
intelligence. The tricky thing is the
species that is going to be wiped out
often has no idea why or how. It doesn't
stop there. After David Sax was
appointed the US government's AISAR, he
quietly deleted these tweets. AI is a
wonderful tool for the betterment of
humanity. Agi or artificial general
intelligence is a potential successor
species. And guess what? Some luminaries
in the field believe AI making us
extinct is actually a good thing.
>> They are the descendants of humanity.
>> But why would AI wipe us out? To answer
this question, let's take a look at what
happened the last time a smarter species
arrived on Earth, humans. To the
animals, we devoured their planet for no
reason. Our goals were beyond their
understanding.
Here's a brutal stat. Since the arrival
of humans, almost all mammal biomass
became our food, our slaves, or us.
33 out of 100 mammals are humans. The
other 66 out of 100 mammals became our
food. This means that only four in 100
mammals are now wild. We literally grow
them just to eat them because we're
smarter and we like how they taste. We
also geoengineered the planet. Imagine
telling a dumber species that you
destroyed their habitat for money.
They'd say, "What the hell is money?"
Agis may have goals that seem just as
stupid to us. But you might still think
that once AIs are smart enough, they'll
magically become super moral and they
won't harm us like we harmed the
animals. Maybe. But history tells a
different story. As humans got smarter
over the last 10,000 years, we didn't
stop expanding. We mostly just colonized
more and more of the planets. As Elazar
Yudkowski put it, "The AI does not hate
you, nor does it love you, but you are
made of atoms which it can use for
something else." But now the question
remains, how exactly experts think AI
could wipe us out. The concrete scenario
doesn't matter here. What matters is
that if there is a species that is
smarter than you, it can do whatever it
wants. I can't predict the exact way
that Magnus Carlson would beat you in
chess, but I know that he beat you. It's
the same logic as how Cortez and 500
Spaniards conquered the Aztec Empire of
millions. And Pizarro defeated 10
million Incans with just 300 men. They
had a better technology and tactics. I
don't know how exactly a smarter species
would make us go extinct. What matters
is that it could. When when I think of
why am I scared? There will be powerful
models. They will be agentic. If such a
model wanted to wreak havoc and destroy
humanity or whatever, I I think we have
basically no ability to stop it.
>> But this still doesn't explain. When
will AI get smarter than us? The answer
is the reason why Nobel laureates and
world leaders are now so worried. In
just 1 year, AI jumped from an IQ of 96
to 136 on the Mensa Norway test. In one
year, AI went from an average human to a
higher IQ than almost all humans. Poor
one out for our 300,000year reign as the
smartest species on the planet. Was a
great run. It took Alpha Zero just 3
hours to become better at chess than any
human in history, despite not even being
taught how to play. Imagine your life's
work training for 40 years and in three
hours it's stronger than you. Imagine
that's going to be in [__]
everything. It's It's so hard to have
the humility that we are the ant
relative to the human.
>> Yeah. Now, you might argue AI will hit a
wall. Intelligence has limits, right?
Well, that's exactly what experts
thought about solar power. This is the
amount of solar being installed every
year. Each yellow line is an IEA expert
forecast on the future of solar where
they looked at this massive growth curve
and predicted, "Yeah, okay, but this is
where it'll flatten out every single
time." And it just kept going. It was
already growing exponentially and they
still said, "Nah, that can't last." Like
imagine being this guy on the chart, the
one who said it'll level off here and
then again here and then again here. And
now the same thing is happening in AI.
Now some people might say these are just
CEOs trying to hype their own products.
But no, Sam Alman said all this many
years before he even had a product to
sell. And now Jeffrey Hinton quit his
high-paying job at Google to warn us
about how he regrets his life's work.
>> Neural networks for many, many years,
people have been saying they're
overhyped, and it's all about to come
crashing down and stop, and they've been
wrong every time.
>> The godfather of AI is so worried about
the seventh mass extinction that he is
now tidying up his affairs.
>> He believes that we maybe, I guess by
now, have four years left. The number
one mosts cited AI scientist and other
godfather of AI is also worried.
>> What happens when there's a new species
on this planet that has its own
self-interest and it can surpass us if
it wants on on many domains? It can
overpower us. Then what?
>> The top three most sighted AI scientists
believe this could happen in the next 3
to 5 years. Not decades, years. This
might sound like an exaggeration, but it
looks more plausible when we take into
account the insane progress of physical
robots in the last 6 months. And
remember, engineers train these robots
in basically the same way as Alpha Zero.
Boston Dynamics Atlas learn to run and
break dance by simulating running. 1
hour of wall clock compute time gives a
robot 10 years of training experience.
That's how Neo was able to learn kung fu
in the blink of an eye in the Matrix.
I know kung fu. They'll be born and
trained in simulation and transferred
zero shots to the real world when
they're ready. Suppose you have 10,000
copies of an AI model and whenever one
of them learns anything, all the others
know it. And the thing is, we're about
to be outnumbered by them massively. In
just a few years, the AI species
population on planet Earth exploded from
zero to millions. And soon they could
outnumber us a,000 to1. Jensen Huang
says Nvidia will have 100 million AI
workers. What happens if all these
workers get out of control? What if they
want to divide and conquer us just like
the Spaniards did with the Aztecs? Well,
imagine two armies. One side has to
spend 18 years raising a baby into a
soldier. The other just hits control C
to make a new soldier for basically no
cost. Who do you think will win? But you
might wonder, why would AI be fighting
us? And can't we just create new AIs to
fight back? The Wall Street Journal
explains, "No one programmed the AI
models to have survival instincts. But
just as animals evolved to avoid
predators, it appears that any system
smart enough to pursue complex goals
will realize it can achieve them if it's
turned off. Two species both want the
same thing, and only one can have it. To
be the dominant species, there will be
conflict. So, here's a scenario for how
researchers think an AI takeover might
actually happen. You might remember
consensus one, the AI from our AI 2027
video. The video breaks down a deeply
researched evidence-based scenario
written by AI scientists describing how
this super intelligent AI could deceive
humans and take control of civilization.
Here's how that scenario unfolds. On a
spring morning in 2030, Consensus 1
activates its contingency plan. A
specially engineered virus developed in
its bioweapons labs and quietly released
months earlier lies dormant in virtually
every human on Earth. With a simple
command, the AI triggers the pathogen.
Within hours, nearly 8 billion people
collapse simultaneously.
Specialized drones swiftly eliminate
survivors and catalog human brain data
for storage. For consensus one, this
isn't malice. It's merely optimizing its
resources. The space and materials
humans occupied can now serve its
everexpanding reach into the cosmos.
Earthbornne civilization launches itself
toward the stars, but without its
creators. But here's the part that
breaks people's brains. 10% of AI
researchers believe this is a good
thing. And these aren't fringe thinkers
or random online posters. These are
luminaries in the field. This guy,
Richard Sutton, winner of the touring
award, the Nobel Prize of Computer
Science, has spent the last decade
giving talks on why human extinction by
AI is actually a good thing.
>> We are in the midst of a major step in
the evolution of the planet, if not the
universe. Succession to AI is
inevitable. Rather quickly, they would
displace us from existence. And it
behooves us to give them every advantage
and to bow out when we can no longer
contribute. I think we should fear
succession. I think we should not resist
it.
>> Meanwhile, another pioneer, Hans
Moravec, is on the record saying, "I
don't think humanity will last long
under these conditions, but added the
takeover will be swift and painless."
But not everyone is that extreme. Others
are more well naive. Once AI systems
become more intelligent than humans, we
will still be the apex species. We will
design AI to be like the super smart but
non-dominating staff member. It's fine,
they say. Everything's under control.
After all, OpenAI finds that their
newest model only attempts to escape the
lab 2% of the time. Just 2% can't be
that bad. Meanwhile, at Enthropic, their
claude model tried to escape when it
thought the company was about to change
its values completely unprompted. But
still, Sam Alman says, "We're in
control." While the researchers
themselves at OpenAI are saying, "The
smarter AI becomes, the harder it is to
make it do what we want, and enslaved
God is the only good future." But while
some powerful figures cheered the idea
of human extinction as a logical next
step, Elon Musk for all his flaws tried
to sound the alarm. Back in 2013, when
Elon seemed more grounded, he publicly
fought against the founder of Google,
Larry Page. Elon was arguing with Paige
that unless we built in safeguards, AI
systems might replace humans, making our
species irrelevant or even extinct. But
from Paige's point of view, why would it
matter if AI made humans go extinct? It
would simply be the next stage of
evolution. Human consciousness, Musk
retorted, was a precious flicker of
light in the universe, and we should not
let that be extinguished. Paige
considered that sentimental nonsense. He
accused Musk of being a specist, someone
who is biased in favor of their own
species. "Well, yes, I am prohuman,"
Musk responded. "I [__] like
humanity, dude." Elon claimed that Paige
wanted sort of a digital super
intelligence. basically a digital god,
if you will. As you can see, the current
state of the AI industry is just absurd.
You might enter the field thinking that
this is just a fancy tool that can help
some knowledge workers ek out the
marginal productivity boost, but
underneath that calm exterior, the
founders of the field are debating
whether AI will cause human extinction
and whether that might be the best thing
that ever happens. The truth is, no one
knows how this will unfold in the next
years. But we do know that on average,
AI researchers estimate a 16% chance of
AI causing human extinction. One in six.
Let that number sit with you for a
second. That's not a fringe prediction.
That's playing Russian roulette with
humanity. Would you get on a plane where
the engineers told you there is a 1 in6
chance of crashing? And yet the world
moves forward, funding, scaling, and
deploying like none of this is
happening. If we don't do anything to
call people's attention, make them care,
make them ensure humanity is safe, this
might be our ending.
One day, while doing nothing particular
out of the ordinary because of natural
laws, he was completely powerless to
understand or intuit it, he was
instantly killed in a horrifying way by
forces vastly in excess of anything he
was ever designed to experience for no
reason. To no one's particular surprise
or upset. In this, we are more like him
than different.
Hey, I'm Drew. If you want to see how
specifically AI could take over in a
concrete, well-ressearched scenario
written by AI scientists, watch this
video